parents could soon have a new tool to
keep their kids safe pfizer has asked
for fda permission to make its covet
vaccine available for kids as young as
six months old now if authorized
children could start getting the first
of two doses by early march these doses
contain just one tenth the amount that
adults get there is a chance that some
kids will need a third dose after fives
are discovered the two dose regimen may
not be enough in two to four year olds
despite the science many parents still
have a lot of reservations about this
shot nikki bates spoke with two young
kids who have participated in a vaccine
trial
siblings lillian and will love playing
superheroes but last year the two got a
real chance to help others by taking
part in a pfizer covet vaccine clinical
trial helping people is a good thing and
helping people is a good thing
they both got two doses of the vaccine
at cincinnati children's hospital i told
my friends that i was gonna give a shot
lillian was four and will was just three
when they were enrolled they were both
great they both did awesome
their mom sarah says she was grateful
both kids got the vaccine we are so
lucky like who in the world can say that
they were all protected
all ahead of schedule soon millions more
children as young as six months old may
be eligible the fda could make its
decision about authorization in the next
few weeks
but experts don't expect authorization
for kids under five to significantly
affect new case numbers which remain
high that's because only 38 percent of
children who are already eligible are
fully vaccinated once it's clear that
the vaccine is safe and effective people
should feel comfortable using it dr paul
offit a member of the fda's vaccine
advisory committee reassures parents the
process will be thorough we will
carefully look at those data and we will
approve that vaccine for children less
than five only if there is a clear and
robust data set for safety and efficacy
for cbs mornings i'm nikki batiste